[Music]
that's adele giving fans a major tease
of her new music absolutely incredible
on saturday the 33 year old british
singer made a surprise appearance on
instagram live where she gave her fans a
taste of her upcoming single easy on me
[Music]
in these waters
but i can't bring myself to swim when i
am drowning in this is
[Music]
adele sat in front of the camera bobbing
her head to the moody tune
[Music]
that's that's it that's all i'm going to
apply
up until now we had only heard the
instrumental part of the song from this
sneak peek adele posted a few days
earlier
[Music]
the singer is set to release the track
from her highly anticipated upcoming
album on october 15th
although she hasn't officially given the
new record a title fans have speculated
that it will be called 30. sticking with
the grammy winner's tradition of naming
her releases after years of her life
her fourth studio album comes two years
after she filed for divorce to simon
kaneki father of their almost
nine-year-old son angelo
the hello singer recently got candid in
an interview with both british and
american vogue talking about the end of
her marriage
quote it just wasn't right for me
anymore i didn't want to end up like a
lot of other people i knew it wasn't
miserable miserable but i would have
been miserable had i not put myself
first
adele explained nothing bad happened
between them and she says she recorded a
lot of her upcoming songs for their son
i have to be in a new mom very tiring
wonderful but tiring
she said quote i just felt like i wanted
to explain to him through this record
when he's in his 20s or 30s who i am and
why i voluntarily chose to dismantle his
entire life in the pursuit of my own
happiness
it made him really unhappy sometimes and
that's a real wound for me that i don't
know if i'll ever be able to heal it's
an amazing thing to show my son you know
and i'm raising him to respect women and
he knows i'm a powerful force he feels
it just at home
let alone you know when he comes to work
with me the 33 year old adds that she
also wanted to show angelo how she
expects him to treat his future partner
quote after going through a divorce my
requirements are sky high there's a very
big pair of shoes to fill and looks like
those shoes have seemingly been filled
as adele also confirmed she's dating
sports agent rich paul
[Music]
adele told the mag he is quote great and
they are very happy
[Music]
that's it that's all i'm going to apply
[Music]